[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 128 that is
about the least prime number we've ever
hit ever ever ever actually probably
mathematically we could evaluate that
based on the number of factors it's got
to be close
but
anyway it's uh it's definitely not prime
so for those of you who were
i don't know
standing ready for a prime number
episode well you'll have to wait a bit
yeah a couple things uh one
um
we both have a cold so if you um detect
a change in our voices that's what's
going on my prediction is that this will
increase the overall sultriness of the
podcast um that will be entirely as a
result of your voice being more sultry
mine will just sound like phlegm yours
is the audience say what yours the
audience
um
mine yes yours no no not the audience we
don't hear their voices i mean if you do
hear their voices that's something i
want to know about because i don't know
it's concerning yeah speaking of which
we're going to talk a little bit about
uh mental health today
we are going to talk a little bit about
mental health and if you are hearing
voices talking about mental health check
they may be ours right um but i will say
this virus reminds me of something okay
this virus that we apparently have this
little cold
it is beautifully designed now i resent
it because it's making me feel
unpleasant
but um
it is
fantastically
infectious all four members of the
family have had it
it is
very slightly virulent doesn't do a lot
of harm and i just i i hope that the
fools who were turbocharging bat plagues
in wuhan and north carolina and
elsewhere would take a lesson from this
virus getting into the future does not
require making people incredibly sick
and to the extent that you were doing
that because of some nonsense you wrote
in your grant applications shame on you
indeed yes
is that your announcements well there
was one more but we have we have a lot
that we haven't done yet you just sort
of launched into talking about having a
cold well i just i wanted them to know
uh you know
why we sound this way
go ahead
you're done yes okay
um we are today going to talk about uh
viktor frankl and man's search for
meaning we're going to talk about uh
electoral politics and the west coast of
the u.s including issues of homelessness
and addiction and mental illness and
crime and policing we're going to talk
about gun control some
we're going to talk about the moral
responsibility to own the corollary of
your claims and what it feels like to
walk around uh american cities now as uh
at least many of the lockdown measures
are using and people seem to be
returning to a mental state that um that
maybe is like one that they had before
but actually as we talked about a little
bit in our episode two days ago um
doesn't actually remind either of us of
anything that we've exactly seen before
so there's a lot a lot that we're going
to be talking about today
i have forgotten to bring up the french
version of our book so we'll do that
next time
um no it's okay we're good uh so uh we
have uh coming up very soon the
publication of hunter gatherer's guide
to the 21st century in both spanish and
french
which we're excited about
and we encourage you if you have not
yet picked up the book in english and if
you're listening in english why not um
to to go there because many of the
arguments that
we make the framing that we have
which is uh you know neither
neither traditionalist nor all progress
is good
is could be viewed as a middle ground
but we view it rather as an evolutionary
lens a lens which understands both what
we are what we have been and what we're
capable of all with an understanding of
the both the hardware and the software
programs and capabilities that we have
as humans who have been evolving on this
planet like everything else on this
planet for
three and a half billion years give or
take um it doesn't feel that long it
does now i you know both both less time
and more time you know how that happens
yeah yeah
yeah i don't really feel the more in
this case it's got a shorter ride for me
13 billion that doesn't
ring any bells for you 13 billion a lot
of that was kind of inanimate yeah yeah
it was it was
okay so um
unfortunately um odyssey was glitching
out on us so we're just on youtube at
the moment uh we will of course uh be on
um all the podcast places and spotify
and and every place else uh shortly
after we live stream here today for the
first time in a while we're doing a q a
uh go over to darkhorsesubmissions.com
as we are live streaming now or during
the q a which will immediately follow
this stream to post any questions that
you have
and you can find additional things that
we're doing at natural selections where
as we talked about two days ago my most
recent post is about the five year
anniversary of evergreen
uh the the place where we were tenured
the college we were tenured for 15 years
blowing up five years ago
and
we are as always grateful to you we are
supported by our audience we appreciate
you subscribing to the channel
liking uh videos sharing videos both the
main channel brett weinstein's channel
and the dark horse podcast clips channel
which has smaller bits bits and pieces
and we would we would remind you as
much as we don't like to that we were
demonetized by youtube last summer and
we have not been remonetized at any
point and that took out a lot of our
income at that point we're demonetized
and demonized at the same time indeed
but that is not actually the point here
um we were demonetized and we have not
been remonetized and as such uh we are
ever more grateful for those who have
the ability and the interest who are
able to support us financially and so
you can join us on patreons for instance
we have our private monthly q a on my
patreon tomorrow at 11 a.m
pacific
and uh we leave it up afterwards for
those who can't join us live although
it's it's a wonderful conversation that
we have and we're able to have the chat
uh
it's it's an intimate enough
conversation that we can interact with
people in the chat and respond to stuff
in real time
and uh of course also we have our
sponsors whom we are very uh very choosy
about uh brett objected to my use of the
term discriminating before but i persist
in believing that we are discriminating
in who we choose as our sponsors i just
feel i deserve to trigger warning well
i'm not going to give you one
yeah typical
yeah i don't i don't do that um
so this week as as per usual we have
three sponsors
so here we go
our first sponsor this week
is mudwater
which is a coffee alternative made with
mushrooms herbs and spices
with one seventh the caffeine is a cup
of coffee you get energy without the
anxiety jitters or crash of coffee
each ingredient was added with intention
it's got cacao and chai lion's mane
cordyceps shaga and reishi turmeric and
cinnamon
and i will say this i enjoy my coffee
but i don't need it and that's
intentional i've spent time places where
coffee was not or might not be available
so it's important to me not to lose
functionality if i can't get it so i
wasn't sure that i needed or wanted this
product but it's great i'm a sucker for
chocolate it's definitely got a hint of
chocolate in it same for their masala
chai blend which includes cinnamon
turmeric ginger cardamom black pepper
nutmeg and cloves
and i really like it blended as i had
this morning with some peanut butter
banana milk and cacao nibs for a rich
smoothie so that is this product their
main mud water masala shy product but
they also now have this product
which
they're calling mud water rest which has
a slightly different list of ingredients
including rooibos chai turkey tail
lucuma valerian passion flower etc
and which has no caffeine and is
designed as a as a you know
non-alcoholic night cap um and that's
really excellent too
mudwater is 100 usda organic non-gmo
gluten-free vegan and kosher certified
and they donate a percentage of revenue
to maps the multi-disciplinary
association for psychedelic studies and
they work with pachama which i may be
mispronouncing but this is not pachamama
this is pachama which pays monthly to
reforestation efforts to ensure that
they have a net positive carbon
footprint mud water allows you to build
a morning ritual that promotes sustained
energy without the crash visit
mudwater.com darkhorse to support the
show and use darkhorse at checkout for
15 off your order that's
mudwtr mudwater
m-u-d-w-t-r.com darkhorse and use
darkhorse at checkout for fifteen
percent off um i was uh studying while
you were reading but did you say net
positive and mean that negative on the
carbon footprint
you know it says net positive here but
yes i i must it's just like morally
positive yeah that negative in terms of
no i i agree and yet that's directly
from what i what i inherited here so um
net good yeah i'm not good but that's i
i agree and i just decide not to correct
myself in real time as i remember well
i've apparently decided to correct you
in real life no no that's that's that's
better but i don't yeah i don't know i
don't know where that error is but
anyway they're they're they're doing
honorable things when it comes to errors
you ain't seen nothing yet watch this
um i doubt it i don't know we'll see
we'll see there i'm i'm correcting typos
on the fly um our second sponsor this
week is eight sleep a relatively new
sponsor for us whom we are excited to
know about and proud to have their
support good sleep is a game changer and
as we discuss in the hunter-gatherer's
guide intelligent life that found its
way to earth might be surprised by a lot
of what found on our planet but likely
not the fact of sleep or dreams sleep is
necessary without good sleep we are
destined to be unhealthy and
unproductive
yet more than 30 percent of americans
struggle with sleep and temperature is
one of the mains reasons it is well
known that individuals in couples who
sleep together often have different
optimal sleep temperatures ain't that
the truth eight sleep allows fine-tuned
temperature regulation for both people
separately i will add having a cool room
and a warm bed is a luxury that ate
sleep
makes easy to obtain and i will just add
that this is such a big problem if you
warm the room up for the person who
wants it warmer than the person who
wants it cooler can't get there because
the best you can do is shed the covers
and there's nowhere to radiate the heat
if the room is warm so
a bed that actually allows you to take
heat out of the bed and radiate it
elsewhere or add extra heat to the bed
if you're too chilly is an awesome thing
we wouldn't have thought that we wanted
it but it turns out to be awesome
the
the pod pro cover by eight sleep is the
most advanced solution on the market for
thermal regulation
you can add the cover to any mattress
and start sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
or as hot as 110 ieiei
not that we recommend those extremes the
temperature of the cover will adjust
each side of the bed based on your sleep
stages biometrics bedroom temperature
and react dynamically to create the
optimal sleeping environment eight sleep
users fall asleep 32 percent faster
reduce sleep interruptions by 40 and get
more restful sleep overall and with 30
percent more deep sleep on average that
restorative sleep will likely help with
physical recovery hormone regulation and
mental clarity finally the alarm feature
which can wake you with temperature
change and or slight chest level
vibrations is so much gentler than a
standard alarm which can't be good for
you let's be honest the standard alarm a
standard alarm cannot be waking up it's
called an alarm do you think waking up
to alarm every day of your life is good
for you i'm bet not
uh we were both a little skeptical but
we are now totally sold and we are
surprised at how much we appreciate this
bed go to 8sleep.com
darkhorse to check out the pod pro cover
and save 150 bucks at checkout eight
sleep ships to the usa canada and the uk
all right not too many errors
all right our final sponsor this week is
ned
a cbd company that stands out in a
highly saturated cbd market
ned was started by two friends who
discovered that their hyper modern lives
were leaving them feeling empty
bewildered and disconnected i'm quoting
now something about this way of life
they say on their website just wasn't
working so they started ned
you can buy cbd products in nearly every
coffee shop or grocery store but ned's
blends stand out their de-stress blend
here i've got it right here there
de-stress blend
there we go
um
i lost my place
i haven't had any today um their
de-stress blend in particular really
impressed us ned's de-stress impresses
us ned's de-stress plan is a one-to-one
formula of cbd and cbg made from the
world's purest full-spectrum hemp and
also features a botanical infusion of
ashwagandha cardamom and cinnamon cbg in
cbg is known as quote the mother of all
cannabinoids i'm not sure exactly by
whom it's known that as by
but apparently it is
cbg is known as the mother of all
cannabinoids because of how effective it
is at combating anxiety and stress by
inhabiting
boy
by inhibiting oh my god the reuptake of
gaba the neurotransmitter responsible
for stress regulation maybe i should
have some now a little bit yeah okay
many of the cbd companies out there
source their hemp from industrial farms
in china just like with low quality
alcohol however low quality cbd can have
undesired effects ned is usda certified
organic all of ned's full spectrum hemp
oil extracted from usda certified
organic camp plants grown by an
independent farmer named jonathan in
payonia colorado
also ned shares third party lab reports
and information about who farms their
products and their extraction process on
their site
these products are science-backed
nature-based solutions that offer an
alternative to prescription and
over-the-counter drugs they're full of
premium cbd and a full spectrum of
active cannabinoids terpenes flavonoids
and trichomes
ned's full spectrum hemp oil nourishes
the body's endocannabinoid system to
offer functional support for stress
sleep inflammation and balance
invest in yourself and fortify your
stress response this month and get 15
off ned's distress blend with code
darkhorse go to helloned.com darkhorse
or enter code darkhorse at checkout
that's h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d
dot com slash dark horse to get 15 off
thank you ned for sponsoring the show
and offering our listeners a natural
remedy for some of life's most common
health issues
all right
that
is our sponsors for this week
i wanted to start by talking a bit about
victor frankl
and this extraordinary book
man's search for meaning which many of
you will know some of you will not know
it all and um
probably
my guess would be the largest category
would be yeah i've heard of that but i'm
not actually totally sure what what's
going on there which is where i was
until um until recently i mentioned on
our last episode that zack and i went to
the holocaust museum in dc when we were
there a week ago a week and a half ago
and a few weeks before that i had found
a copy of this book
on um
on our friend dave stevens carefully
curated uh library on his boat when we
were with him in the bahamas and he had
uh encouraged me to to read it when i
said you know i've been meaning to and i
haven't he said
do
and he offered you his copy he often
find it because that's the kind of guest
you are he offered me his copy even
though he had you know he's on a boat he
had a tiny library because he's on a
boat and i wasn't going to take his his
copy so um this is not his copy but he
would he was willing to give give me his
copy
um
and then
i've also been listening to and i think
we'll end up talking a little bit about
um
this later today i've also been
listening to michael schellenberger's uh
book san francisco on
audiobook recently and i find him also
invoking frankel and man search for
meaning
so there are a whole lot of things
pointing to pointing to this and i
finally picked it up yesterday and i
think i've mentioned you know i'm an
avid reader but i'm not that fast a
reader but i read the book yesterday
and
and it really
it really touched me deeply in so many
ways so
um i'm going to share a few excerpts and
i've talked to you brett a little bit
about it but not a ton uh and i believe
you have not read it but you're of
course familiar with with him and some
of his story but let me tell a little
bit about his story and then read a few
expert experts
it's going to be that kind of day uh
read a few excerpts uh to for us to talk
about uh so frenkel was born in vienna
in 1905 he was a psychiatrist he became
a psychiatrist he wasn't a psychiatrist
when he was born interestingly uh yeah
he was like under underachiever i guess
later yes
uh no you know so so like the opposite
of the underachiever um
born in vienna in 1905 became a
psychiatrist and he founded uh what has
been since called the third school of
viennese psychotherapy freud having
founded the first alfred adler having
founded the second and frankel's what
became called what became known
by him as logotherapy became known as
the third school of viennese
psychotherapy
the main tenet of which is that the
primary motivation for humans is to find
meaning in their life
and um
here before i say a little bit more
about what what his story is um
hear from
an afterward in the book that he writes
a long time later
as logotherapy teaches there are three
main avenues on which one arrives at
meaning in life the first is be create
by creating a work or by doing a deed
the second is by experiencing something
or encountering someone in other words
meaning can be found not only in work
but also in love
most important however is the third
avenue to meaning in life even the
helpless victim of a hopeless situation
facing a fate he cannot change may rise
above himself may grow beyond himself
and by so doing change himself he may
turn a personal tragedy
into a triumph
very interesting taxonomy it's quite an
interesting taxonomy isn't it and i
haven't heard one like it before uh
by 1939 remember he was born in 1905 by
1939 frankel was the head of neurology
at rothschild hospital in
vienna was the only jewish hospital in
vienna at the time
after the nazis closed the hospital down
he was offered an american visa in 1942
which would have allowed him uh to
escape and to complete the book that he
was working on which was to be his first
formalization of his
of logotherapy
he
let the visa expire though because he
did not want to abandon his parents
in vienna
that same year in 1942
he and his new wife and his parents were
imprisoned in a concentration camp for
him it was the first of four
concentration camps that he would be
imprisoned in
which included auschwitz
he took with him the manuscript for the
book that he was writing that would
become
his his thesis on logotherapy and it was
of course taken from him um at at intake
at the first concentration camp that he
was at and lost
while imprisoned by the nazis frankel
found meaning broadly in two sources
the prospect of being reunited with his
loved ones specifically his wife and his
parents he was with his father in that
first camp and he
unfortunately was was witness to his
father's decline and death so he knew
that he had lost his father at some
point
but he kept alive in his head the love
that he felt for and the voice of
specifically his his wife but also of
his the rest of his family that he
was hoping was still alive
and he also found meaning in those many
years that he was imprisoned in that
series of concentration camps
the prospect of rewriting his manuscript
now informed by his horrific years
seeing death and narrowly escaping death
himself in the nazi camps
on april 27th 1945 frankel was liberated
the camp was liberated and frankel
became free
and shortly thereafter he learned that
none of his family had survived everyone
was gone
he wrote the first edition of this book
man's search for meaning over nine
successive days within a year of the
camp's liberation
and there is there are a couple of
afterwards epilogues in this version of
the book now that he wrote later he went
on to live a very long life a very a
very successful productive meaningful
life
uh but the vast majority of this book
was written in nine days within a year
of him escaping from the horror that was
the holocaust and imprisonment in the
concentration camps
so i have a couple of sections to read
given that background on on
frankel's story
the prisoner who had lost faith in the
future his future was doomed
with his loss of belief in the future he
also lost his spiritual hold he let
himself decline and became subject to
mental and physical decay
usually this happened quite suddenly in
the form of a crisis the symptoms of
which were familiar to the experienced
camp inmate we all feared this moment
not for ourselves which would have been
pointless but for our friends
usually it began with the prisoner
refusing one morning to get dressed and
wash or to go out on the parade grounds
no in treaties no blows no threats had
any effect he just lay there hardly
moving
if this crisis was brought about by an
illness he refused to be taken to the
sick bear to do anything to help himself
he simply gave up
there he remained lying in his own
excreta and nothing bothered him anymore
i once had a dramatic demonstration of
the close link between the loss of faith
in the future and this dangerous giving
up
a friend who i call just by his first
initial f my senior block warden a
fairly well-known composer in librettis
confided in me one day i would like to
tell you something doctor i have had a
strange dream a voice told me that i
could wish for something that i should
only say what i wanted to know and all
my questions would be answered what do
you think i asked but i would like to
know when the ward be over for me you
know what i mean doctor for me i want to
know when we when our camp would be
liberated and our sufferings come to an
end
and when did you have this dream i asked
in february 1945 he answered it was then
the beginning of march
what did your dream voice answer
affordably he whispered to me march 30th
when f told me about his dream he was
still full of hope and convinced that
the voice of his dream would be right
but as the promised day drew nearer the
war news which reached our camp made it
appear very unlikely that we would be
free on the promise date
on march 29th f suddenly became ill and
ran a high temperature on march 30th the
day his prophecy had told him that the
war and suffering would be over for him
he became delirious and lost
consciousness
on march 31st he was dead
to all outward appearances he had died
of typhus
those who know how close the connection
is between the state of mind of a man
his courage and hope or lack of them and
the state of immunity of his body will
understand that the sudden loss of hope
and courage can have a deadly effect
the ultimate cause of my friend's death
was that the expected liberation did not
come and he was severely disappointed
this suddenly lowered his body's
resistance against the latent typhus
infection his faith in the future and
his will to live had become paralyzed
and his body fell victim to illness and
thus the voice of his dream
was right after all
wow i mean we all
i think we all accept that there is a
statistically disproportionate uh
likelihood of somebody dying after a
major event like 100th birthday or
something
like this so obviously these mechanisms
exist you and i could talk at length
about why evolution would have built
such mechanisms they're a little bit
paradoxical but i don't think so
so hard to understand
um but
it makes perfect sense that uh one's
cognitive understanding of there being a
point in living further would have a
dramatic implication for one's
homeostasis effectively
and um
yeah i i i think the thing is most of us
don't get a chance to to see it enough
to know that it's real and so it's a
it's a very abstract phenomenon but the
camps concentrated this kind of tragedy
so much that there was the ability to
see the pattern yeah they concentrated a
lot of things didn't they yeah
and i think we all can see this with
regard to much you know
much less dire outcomes than death
uh what isn't included in that little
excerpt i just read is that frankel
himself was i think in charge of the
typhus ward which meant that he
also had typhus because he was exposed
all the time and he he saw that so many
of the prisoners had this low level of
typhus that was largely not killing them
and then something would happen and
and
people would die and so in this case
it's not that the man became infected
with typhus and that he died the man had
been infected with typhus for a long
time
and he had found his meaning he had
found his hope in this external measure
over which he had no control
and pinned everything on it such that as
it became clear that his hope was
unfounded
he lost all of his sense of meaning and
this is this is part of the work of
frankl and as we will see in a couple
more
slightly shorter excerpts that i'll
share
um that you know finding your meaning
through
work or a deed through love through
emerging stronger from deep hardship
those are his three that was his
taxonomy that that i read from to begin
with
is extraordinary and really
really allows for so many possibilities
right
yeah um
i'm i'm caught here because there are
several or several different things that
are relevant one you know what are we
right evolutionarily speaking we are
trying to get our genes deeply into the
future which is a kind of a pointless
mundane and devoid of meaning activity
on the other hand we have this marvelous
architecture that can make meaning of
the universe and many of us who do make
meaning
see it as paramount even if it is
subordinate to the other thing
and so
i guess the question is
i think it is apparent that physiology
we all know it involves a lot of
trade-offs we don't can't be specific
about them but the ability to borrow
from some capacity
uh exists in other words there are lots
of things where you can stave off
um
a
set of symptoms and then you crash at
the point that you can right i've often
been impressed when i was a younger
person i did more backpacking i was
often impressed by how infrequently you
ran into somebody on the trail
who you know had the flu or something
and was in the terrible pickle that
you'd be in out you know in you know in
the back country unable to i did once
encounter somebody with giardia who who
soldiered on but
um
well that's a very acute thing that he
present presumably wasn't harboring for
right a while picked it up he picked it
up and it hit him and yeah um but there
are lots of things you can borrow there
are lots of resources you can borrow
from but you really are borrowing the
point is the cost of that borrowing is
substantial and it hits you hard and you
can imagine that a prisoner expecting to
be freed
that if their physiology really did have
an understanding that like i have to get
to this point because that's the point
at which things will immediately get
better and then it is apparent that they
are not going to get better then the
point is well i already spent it right i
borrowed to get me to that day
and now i have nowhere to borrow from
so um you know it's terrifying that our
minds are that connected to our
physiology but i don't think uh
i don't think it's actually all that
surprising yeah no i agree
okay
next short excerpt
by the same token every human being has
the freedom to change at any instant
i'm gonna elide a bunch of what he
writes here but then say freedom however
is not the last word
freedom is only part of the story and
half of the truth
freedom is but the negative aspect of
the whole phenomenon whose positive
aspect is responsibleness
in fact freedom is in danger of
degenerating into mere arbitrariness
unless it is lived in terms of
responsibleness
that is why i recommend the statue of
liberty on the east coast be
supplemented by a statue of
responsibility on the west coast
so
um you know he obviously was writing
let's see this is later this is in the
in the early 80s uh but uh he did not
see what the west coast of the united
states is currently enveloped in and
enmeshed in
boy could we use that could we use a
statue of liberty and a statue of
responsibleness as he calls it a
responsibility uh in this case and
and see the tension between them and
feel the necessity of both
yeah i think
we have a
um
a propensity to squander
valuable things
and it's really important that we learn
not to do it right so you know you can
have free speech for example and you can
use it
pointlessly you can use it to go be a
troll and make people's lives worse and
yep that's a built-in downside of having
that freedom but the point is really
okay
the freedom is important but it's sort
of a prerequisite to doing something
useful with it and but you don't acquire
the skill to do something useful with it
unless somebody
sort of says look the objective of the
exercise you know this is part of why
i'm
uh increasingly troubled by the concept
of recreation
which i just i know it seems like wow
what kind of freaking buzzkill do you
have to be to be against recreation
but i think the point is recreation
is
um
inherently
devoid of value and that we have words
for recreation that you know recreation
is the the uh
the hedonistic version and the point is
you're supposed to be having fun as much
as you can but fun is supposed to be a
reward for doing something awesome right
like wooing the right person right
you're supposed to have a great deal of
fun with that person right but if you
can instead have a
computer simulation of a right person
who actually just sends you the right
messages as if you were you know really
a compelling you know partner then okay
yeah you may feel just as you would if
you had actually like you know won
somebody's heart that you valued but
what did you do but we know that you
don't i mean that's that that's what's
at the base of this is that we can
we our modern environment our hyper
novelty and our technology have figured
out how to trigger many of the
short-term reward circuits
um but what there is no
you know market
benefit in doing and what is also much
more complicated to do and no one has
figured out how to do is how to actually
replace the long-term reward circuits
without actually doing the thing right
doing doing doing the work doing the
thing finding the value sourced in your
meaning from doing a deed or or creating
a thing or discovering something or
finding love or emerging stronger from a
terrible set of events all of these
kinds of ways that you can find meaning
as frankl describes them
actually then result in joy
and to short-circuit the like yeah but i
just want the joy part
it's going to be shallow it's inherently
shallow yeah it's like behavioral
cocaine or something
and i think i think you've hit the nail
on the head which is that there are
these places where something doesn't
work because the short-term version
out-competes the long-term version
because you have to wait in order to do
your calculation for the long-term
version to show itself to be superior so
yeah in terms of you know the kind of
you know joy and happiness that arises
from some exercise of deep meaning which
takes a long time and somebody who can
trigger that same circuit you know
within an hour if you pay the right
amount
right the point is yeah it's really hard
for the meeting thing
to show itself to be better yeah and
this is part of what we you know
this is what markets do very very badly
right they allow people to figure out
how to trigger every one of these reward
circuits um without your investment
because of course then you'll pay with
money to short to you know to make to
take the shortcut but it's not good for
you it's not good for you
and
well
there's a lot to say here let's
let me go to my penultimate excerpt here
as to the causation of the feeling of
meaninglessness one may say albeit in an
oversimplifying vein that people have
enough to live by but nothing to live
for
they have the means but no meaning
to be sure some actually i'm going to
pause here for a moment let me just
remind the audience
that this is a man who
lived through years in the concentration
camps
and through dento a lot of luck and most
people were not lucky but also
a set of skills and a set and an
understanding of how to find meaning and
therefore to hold on to hope
he survived he was also exceedingly
lucky and most of the people who were
capable of doing exactly what he did
just weren't lucky but here is a man who
is not
accepting that you cannot change your
life and that you cannot take
responsibility for your life so let me
let me start
going i wanted to add something to that
which is
the way you describe the story
it is also
a fact
that his
failure to understand that the loved
ones he was living to see again were
already gone presumably saved his life
because they provided meaning and
prevented him from getting into the
state where he just wouldn't get out of
bed and would die
and
you know this is the reality
of the human animal this is the place
where if you are too narrow in your
understanding you will say well
you know
it was a fiction that kept him alive
right he believed they were alive but
they really weren't and so you know
it's nothing and the point is it's
exactly the opposite it's the opposite
of nothing right
for the same reason that we do not
behave like most animals and simply at
the point that we discover that uh an
intimate of ours is gone just move on
and say okay well i guess i gotta you
know uh you know not set a place for
them at the dinner table and i you know
i guess they won't be uh picking up my
dry cleaning and you know lots of
creatures move on
some creatures don't right and the point
is there's a reason for that and it's
not because being debilitated by sadness
is good it's because something is very
good and being debilitated by sadness is
inextricably linked to it
right and when we talk about we talk
about grief we've talked about grief a
fair bit we talk about it in the book uh
i am often
thrown by otherwise very savvy
intellectually sophisticated thinkers
drawing this hard this bright line
between humans and non-human animals in
this regard
all of the many of the usual suspects by
which i mean the long-lived social
organisms with long childhoods and
generational overlap where they live
with multiple generations in the same
social group have grief you have the
famous case of a chimp whose name i've
forgotten i think out of gambi i think
it was one of the one of the
chimps in the troupe that that goodall
originally
uh habituated and studied
carried around the increasingly
mummified corpse of her infant for weeks
i believe
elephants
will will return over and over and over
again to the corpse of a dead one
especially the matriarch
in a family i think baboons are known to
do this
uh i've seen it in wales we see it in
whales for sure
dogs
dogs
so uh it does not
this is
this is a place where a
a s
a strictly humans are special and
everything else is different
understanding of the universe really
does fall short it
really fails to understand what we are
and what grief is well in fact it short
circuits
the important meaning what you and i get
because we know what it means
we know all those organisms are very far
separated on the phylogeny what that
means is that again and again every time
uh selection builds a
highly
social creature with generational
overlap it cannot help but inflict grief
upon it grief that is
so reliable that we can see it easily in
these other creatures it is impossible
to miss in fact
grief is the downside of love grief is
the downside of love and you know
boy is that a lesson about meaning right
right and it doesn't require that the
one you love
remains alive right the point is it's a
it's a real
connection to something and yeah
don't don't don't miss it because you
can do a narrow analysis in which you
know someone is suddenly you know their
line of the phylogeny has stopped right
okay uh i'm going to restart this little
excerpt
from again man search for meaning
as the causation of the feeling of
meaninglessness one may say albeit in an
oversimplifying vein that people have
enough to live by but nothing to live
for they have the means but no meaning
to be sure some do not even have the
means in particular i think of the mass
of people who are today unemployed
50 years ago i published a study devoted
to a specific type of depression i had
diagnosed in cases of young patients
suffering from what i called
unemployment neurosis
and i could show that this neurosis
really originated in a two-fold
erroneous identification
being jobless was equated with being
useless and being useless was equated
with having a meaningless life
consequently whenever i succeeded in
persuading the patients to volunteer in
youth organizations adult education
public libraries and the like in other
words as soon as they could fill their
abundant free time with some sort of
unpaid but meaningful activity their
depression disappeared although their
economic situation had not changed and
their hunger was the same
the truth is that man does not live by
welfare alone
that line
right there the truth is that man does
not live by welfare alone strikes me as
the
incisive rejoinder to so much that is
wrong in so-called lefty politics at the
moment the idea that all we have to do
is erase the current problems that
people have
um that we have identified as the main
problems that they have and then
everything will be fine we'll we i think
we'll talk a little bit later about how
how the naming of situations uh affects
how we view what we should do how for
instance just to jump ahead a little bit
how referring to people is homeless as
opposed to talking about people on the
streets who are itinerant or transient
or mentally ill or drug addicted
allows us to imagine that providing them
permanent homes will solve all of the
other problems when of course there is
abundant evidence that this is not going
to be sufficient
and that to me that brings us right back
to the truth is that man does not live
by welfare alone yes which actually goes
back to the taxonomy that you raised at
the beginning because one of the things
one of the paradoxes
is that kids in wealthy families have
all sorts of advantages with which you
might imagine they would be at advantage
in pursuing meaning but they may in fact
be hobbled
because they have it too easy and so
learning to produce meaning is not
automatic whereas you know yes
let's say you come from hard scrabble
background and in order to get out of it
you have to build a business well then
by the time you've done that you know
something and so what meaning is is more
intuitive to you than somebody who would
have to bootstrap it you know in a
circumstance where it simply wasn't
required to get all sorts of rewards and
although evergreen is a strange
exception to this
the the chaos that has erupted on
college campuses in the last
five plus years has largely been a
problem of the private elite schools
with the private elite kids
who
come from some family wealth whereas the
community colleges don't have this
problem so much now increasingly the
faculty and the administrators at those
schools are bringing the problems to
them
but at least as of five and seven years
ago when we were still embedded and
higher at ourselves what we were hearing
from our colleagues uh at community
colleges versus at the elite schools was
the students at the elite schools were
very interested in buying into a lot of
the everyone's a victim ideology and the
people at the community colleges many of
which were paying their own way through
school had full-time jobs maybe they
already had families they had no family
support they had lots of stuff going on
and they were sacrificing and they knew
exactly what they were sacrificing in
order to be there they weren't having
any of it yeah and actually now that you
mention it i would say that what
happened at evergreen was that the
faculty brought it yes and uh you know
it's not to say no student brought it
through the door because it was in the
ethos and it was circulating uh on
social media and so many students will
have had contact with it but although
what we saw was actually it was um to
the degree that we could see
where it started among the students it
was among the the rich students they're
interested in sure because they had the
built-in sense of safety that allowed
them to experiment with the anarchy
right
you've got to be pretty safe
the built-in safety which allows you to
experiment with anarchy there it is yeah
there it is but yeah um but i do think
also the comparison between our classes
and the classes that um melted the
school down is pretty clear right the
fact is lots of students walk through
the doors to our classes
they didn't know what they were going to
get but what they got was uh
you know a broad-minded
view of
you know where we are and it wasn't a
view that said things are fair you know
pull yourself up by your bootstraps it
was a thing that said
you know we're we do have built-in
suspicions of other races and we will
default into that if we don't have
better opportunities so we better
protect those you know we better protect
an egalitarian system as an alternative
and i think the fact is you can actually
you can see this i i keep mentioning
that
i didn't understand
when the students that i'd never met 50
of them that i'd never met confronted me
at my classroom i did not know for
months until i had seen mike nena's
very elegant little documentary i didn't
know what it was that they had intended
to accomplish because the chances that i
was going to
you know resign or be fired because they
were chanting at me were zero
what they expected was my students to
defect and my students
didn't think to defect because they knew
me so well that they knew that what was
being said was preposterous and so
really what it says is you've got all
these people ready to be educated you've
got faculty who are all about you know
this victim hierarchy schema and then
you've got other faculty who are about
no there's a more subtle way of looking
at this and actually the students will
go either way well i think actually i
think uh if you'll forgive me i can fit
this into my taxonomy uh that i created
before evergreen blew up at the point
that i was growing quite wary with many
of our colleagues
and you've heard this formulation many
times before but what i said was at the
bar
uh
the very low bar that anyone who is
allowed to
instruct undergraduates should meet is
that they know something of value that
they can communicate and that they
fundamentally believe in the humanity of
all of their students and too many too
many college faculty fail on frankly
both of those counts yes they would not
belly up to that bar of yours
they certainly couldn't couldn't go over
it um
but the the point there was
i don't remember now
um
damn i feel bad sorry uh
yeah okay so let me just finish up what
i was going to be doing then
um
you want to riffle i try to remember
what i was talking about
um well let's see no it's okay i'll just
okay i'll just skip it um
okay so the final the final excerpt here
from
man's search for meaning
is
from the final the very final sentences
of his original edition this is what he
wrote in those nine days within a year
of being freed from the concentration
camp
he says
and i can't find
i apologize i can't find the right
sentence where is it
um
it's supposed to be right here
book darts never lie ah book darts never
oh there it is okay um
in the concentration camps for example
in this living laboratory and on this
testing ground we watched and witnessed
some of our comrades behave like swine
while others behaved like saints
man has both potentialities within
himself which one is actualized depends
on decisions but not on conditions
our generation is realistic for we have
come to know man as he really is after
all man is that being who invented the
gas chambers of auschwitz however he is
also that being who entered those gas
chambers upright with the lord's prayer
or the shema israel on his lips
we are both
we are both things we are the worst of
what we have been and we are the best of
what we have been
and
it is
to our enduring detriment that we
imagine that we are only one
or that we imagine that any human being
has only one
in him and this is also one of frankel's
uh repeating points throughout the book
that he saw
he saw goodness
in some of the concentration camp guards
and he saw evil
in some of his fellow prisoners
and it was harder to view
evil in the prisoners
than it was to view evil in the cards
and it was more
reassuring to see any little tiny hints
of goodness among the guards
than to be good to one another as
prisoners because in both cases those
were unexpected but the fact that
they're unexpected is in part his point
that
we all
can behave differently than we are
currently behaving in both directions
and we should not either
be held responsible for
the failures of the group nor should we
hold ourselves to a past
that we may feel we did not do what we
do the best that we could do we can do
better in the future
yeah you know
um it's interesting to hear
the idea that he saw evil in his in his
fellow inmates sometimes and saw
goodness in the guards it really can't
be otherwise
and i think this is one of the points
that jordan peterson
makes really really well and people have
a hard time with it but you know and i
think we make it a different way which
is that you know evolution has built all
of our best characteristics and our
worst and the real question is
are we going to be
a slave to the mechanism that simply
wants to get our genes into the future
so badly that it will default to
whichever mode is most effective at that
moment
or are we going to say
sorry evolution you blew it giving us
the ability to choose and we are going
to choose something that's worthy of us
and we are going to reject things no
matter how effective they would be at
getting our genes into the future that
are unacceptable and that's really where
we have to be and we are losing ground
on that at the moment which is why some
of us are so animated about the you know
the little battles over nonsense that
will be
forgotten 20 years from now because no
no rational person could possibly
believe it it doesn't matter the point
is that is the sound of us
relinquishing control to the mechanisms
in which we demonize each other in order
to justify what we do to each other and
we simply mustn't
simply mustn't if you have any idea what
happens after you make that step you
know that we simply mustn't
that's right
so there's a lot of places you want to
go yeah and i feel like
that brings up many of the themes that i
think that you want to cover some of
which you want to cover i don't know
about you wanted to surprise me and so
i'm not i am now
leaving it to you all right tell us
where where and when and how i wanted to
start with a concept that i think uh
increasingly i know that we need it we
need to be able to discuss i believe it
is true but we need to be able to
discuss whether it is true in order that
later we can
reach for it
one of the things that i think is
disrupting our
collective
i hate the term collective sense making
now given the way it gets uh abused but
for lack of a better term one of the
things that's disrupting our clients
collective sense making
is that people do not understand that
they own the downsides of their own
arguments
and i want to give a couple of cases of
this so you can see how it plays into
the particular focus of the moment right
which has to do with the implications of
a massacre and what it says about what
we should or shouldn't do with respect
to gun control in the us but i want to
start with an analogy that will be
clearer
if we think back to
some of the earlier battles in the covid
public health sphere
there were lots of people who for
example argued
that we because we raised questions
about the safety and effectiveness of
the coveted vaccines were guilty of
killing a great many people right and
indeed it is true
that if the vaccines were
safe and
net effective
that as we said at the time that it is
inevitable that there would be people
who would lose their life if they
avoided them on the basis that we didn't
know fully what their safety and
effectiveness
profile was that's unavoidable but
if you say not that lives will be lost
as a result of the argument you're
making which is true but you say you are
guilty of killing people by voicing that
argument because you will cause
hesitancy well then guess what
you just bought
the other side of that argument which is
if it turns out that the vaccines are
not harmful if they for example have a
net increase in all-cause mortality for
those who took them then now by virtue
of your own logic you have become
responsible for those deaths now does
that mean that we're responsible if the
vaccines are net positive and you're
responsible if they're not negative no
because we didn't make that argument the
argument we made was that the net
savings of life comes from a discussion
in which we work our way as quickly and
as rigorously as possible to a correct
conclusion about what the right way to
think about these things and the right
effect is and had we done that
we would have
resulted in a intense risk
stratification we would only have
discussed the possibility of vaccinating
people for whom there was the potential
of these things being net positive and
we would have excluded from all of the
adverse events and and other phenomena
many people who simply didn't need them
at some level what you're arguing is
that words have consequences
and that uh what we hear
what you have been told is things like
words are cheap ideas are cheap all
right
well ideas
aren't cheap at least if they are
carefully formulated and
words when they are accusations that
come with them uh the potential for
uh you know in inciting of uh
hatred and actual harm
have consequences and one of the
consequences that you are describing is
you are responsible for
for the corollary arguments yes you are
responsible for the corollaries of your
own arguments and that's not that's not
us that that's doing that to you that's
you that did that to you and you didn't
realize you were doing it presumably or
you were so arrogant to be that sure of
your argument that you didn't care
because you thought it couldn't possibly
be otherwise and you were wrong
um but i want to change that a little
bit it's not that words have consequence
that's true
it is that um
that arguments have logical consequences
right and the point is you make an
argument and you alone you know there
doesn't need to be another person on
planet earth you yourself are signing up
for things that logically follow from
the things you say and how how bad that
is for you
depends on what you do when you discover
it wasn't wrong but that it wasn't right
yeah right if you make a bad argument
right at the point you discover it was a
bad argument or that it wasn't quite
correct what you do is you go back and
you say you know what i misunderstood
that and the point is that doesn't
completely negate the consequences but
it means that you're not continuing to
be responsible for new harm that flows
from the argument that you deployed so
you have an awful lot of control over
how much responsibility actually belongs
to you but that's the concept the point
is you make an argument and then in
argument space all sorts of things
belong to you that you just bought right
that was you it wasn't us
and
in any case i'm
i think we've been very very careful uh
to phrase arguments not in terms of
personally you know
accusing other people of of doing harm
um but that this principle is important
and we have to be able to reach for it
you are responsible for the corollaries
to your own arguments right and
uh you should make arguments knowing
that that is the case
now the reason i raise it has nothing to
do with covet or vaccines or early
treatment or any of those things to
which this applies but it has to do with
our current predicament right we've just
had this
major jaw dropping
massacre in texas
and
unfortunately
it raises all kinds of issues as it
always does in the u.s when these things
happen
and the argument is very
low quality but it is also a case in
which many people who at the very least
have failed to challenge nonsense that's
been advanced under one team's banner
are now very loudly proclaiming logical
conclusions that do not follow and have
been crippled by the arguments that they
themselves have at least tolerated if
not made we'll spell that out yeah
so to the extent that you have
participated in
the demonizing of the police right the
phony
belief that the police are a net bringer
of violence right we all know that there
is police violence and that that's very
bad and i think we all know that it
could be less than it is substantially
and certainly some of it will have a
racial component though i don't think we
know
how much and it's not nearly as much as
portrayed but to the extent
that um the blm riots involved the claim
that all cobs were bastards and in many
places including portland where we live
the argument was made that the police
are not even
deserving of the right to live right the
murder of police was actually called for
regularly in graffiti and elsewhere and
this was tolerated what was also
tolerated were attacks on
police stations as i described in an
earlier stream that we did
there are still police stations in
portland that have just simply been
boarded up and the broken glass you know
hangs in the the atrium and the atrium
is dark because it's all plywood over
so
that is the environment we have built
around policing and now we are in a
situation where we are looking at this
massacre and we are saying
um what is the implication
for
the right
uh to own
firearms in the u.s right we're looking
at that implication and we are looking
at the police and we are saying what
should have happened here and i i don't
actually know how much you have looked
at
what the incident in uvalde
was and what the police response was and
what people are increasingly troubled by
is it a story you've been
uh looking at in in depth
not in-depth
so
there is this very long period after the
police are on the scene in which they're
taking no action and i think in the end
uh
when we finally know all of the things
that took place it will turn out that
that was clearly a terrible error that
had dire consequences
that said
all of the people
that i hear
critiquing this do not appear to be
careful about what environment it is
that police are doing policing in and i
just
i thought it made sense um you know it's
very easy to uh to imagine that after
the fact
we know exactly what everyone should
have done
and uh after years of having their jobs
and livelihoods demonized
being told now well obviously this time
you should have acted fast
um
seems like probably they should have but
uh
just yesterday
just last week just a month ago just a
year ago
these same people were being demonized
and um actually advised that they should
die
right and you know it's different in
texas on the other hand we're all
participating in a national environment
in which these things were frequently
said and you know here in portland uh as
in
seattle and san francisco and los
angeles there's a
notable
lack of policing and mostly it is
people's habit of obeying the law that
is continuing to maintain order
but you know you demonize the police and
at some point they listen to you and it
it has reduced their enthusiasm for
enforcing the law now i don't think that
that's what happened in texas but i just
want to lay out you know
a scenario just so that people at least
have something to you know put a guard
rail on their tendency to just say well
obviously you know i think it's 19 kids
and two teachers died and there was this
long period of time in which the shooter
was unchallenged inside the school
obviously that should have been
different but
let's suppose that the police had
um
had rushed in
and let's suppose that an officer
had
shot the gunman and only 10 children had
died but the police officer had shot one
child and a teacher in the process
now
trolley problem wise
that's better right but we can't know
both futures right that had that
happened we would now be talking about
what had gone wrong in the police
response that
children and
teachers were caught in the crossfire
in some quarters that policeman would
now be being called a murderer
something
you know
what if the police officer was white and
the teacher was hispanic right what
added
situation does this what added uh spin
is this going to add to the fury over
what went wrong in uvalde right so
you know
there is
there is a principle called qualified
immunity which is supposed to give
police
knowledge of their own security so that
they can do what's right and if it
doesn't go well effectively it's a good
samaritan provision but for
professionals
the problem is i don't know what the
state of this thing is now right i don't
know that in an environment
where the blue team is actually
championing and championing the idea in
this case blue stands for democrats not
police
right that's a that's a good distinction
yes when i say the blue team i mean uh
the democratic party is cynically
partnered with
uh a mob that is actively demonizing
police that is
imposing racist interpretations on all
sorts of unfortunate scenarios that
don't have a racial component and so the
point is that cannot help but arrive
with the police
right
i'm reminded actually of uh of an
article written by a a new friend of
mine alana redstone that i wrote about
in natural selections a couple weeks ago
in which she tells a story she's a
apologies dr redstone i think a
sociologist at uh university of illinois
champagna champagne urbana champagne and
she asks her students if a person
a reasonable person could understand
what happened to george floyd
without invoking a racial component
and at first she's surprised that the
responses come back like 60 of her
students are like yeah a reasonable
person could understand what happened
there without invoking uh racism
basically but then it turns out through
further questioning that what reasonable
person what is hiding and reasonable
person in the students heads is because
they're ignorant
because you know reasonable people can
be ignorant but if they knew what i know
then that number the percentage of
students who actually thinks that you
can understand that scene that that that
whole terrible thing that happened
almost two years ago almost exactly two
years ago now
um
could not be understood without without
framing it in racial terms goes and i
don't remember what the numbers are but
far far lower
and so you know that is the environment
into which now you know two years later
this happens but our entire world has
and and since before george floyd of
course the the the explicitly racialized
context in which we are expected to
engage all of our fellow human beings as
brought to us by frankly charlatans like
ibrahmax kendy and uh robin d'angelo
with their best-selling books that have
told us that if we don't focus on race
at all times we are ourselves actively
being racist by doing so when in fact
it's exactly the opposite
has created a world in which
how could you not hesitate
if you are about to go in and try to
help someone
and there's a possibility that you're
trying to help
might not be perfect and you then might
be accused of doing exactly the harm
that you are absolutely opposed to in
the world
yeah we have effectively created a
minefield where the legal environment
and
the social condemnation mirror
the predicament that we all face online
where we know that basically the terms
of
service um
cannot be followed right you will find
out after the fact what the rules were
right because somebody will throw an
interpretation on the terms of service
that puts you over them so i'm not
saying it's i think it's obvious to me
that you had a lot of well-armed cops
who were there well before the shooting
stopped right
i think they should have maneuvered a
vehicle i mean you know we got to
remember this guy
had a an ar-15
i don't know what the walls were made of
but they can certainly go through almost
anything that they would have so even
just approaching the building you know
without knowing where the shooter is
inside is risky but they could have
maneuvered a vehicle close to the
building they could have you know i
don't know use periscopes or these uh
video scopes that you know you you know
basically the end of some flexi stock
you could peer in a window and figure
out where it is i think something should
have been happening that whole time i
share that suspicion with people but i
also
understand that we have given cops an
unsolvable puzzle and if the idea is
look
the puzzle that we gave them
means that they are on the hook for
anything they do that doesn't go well
and they prioritize not doing then the
point is
well that's on them because there were
children and innocent teachers in that
building but it's also on the people who
did that demonizing who should have seen
this coming right so
that's my that's my point about the
downsides of arguments and into this
environment of course we're losing
police right and left you know not only
are police departments being
being in some cases defunded although
behind the scenes then a little bit more
money is coming back into them um but
many of the best best cops
um either did not apply you know the
future best cops went like not going
into that field um or retired early or
like yep i'm i'm out of here or we're
driven out by mandates and so the point
is we've done we've driven we've done
all kinds of things to reduce the
effectiveness of our police and now
we're like well where the hell were the
police well it's like well have you been
paying attention yeah right have you
been paying attention over the last two
years what we've done to the police
right you don't think that played a role
here because i do
um so anyway that that's important but
i've also you know if this of course
brings up all of the basic you know the
the
stalemate that has existed over gun
control versus second amendment rights
in the us
is always brought up predictably when we
have a mass shooting like this
and the problem is that i feel so first
of all people who are curious about what
my position is i won't speak for you but
people who are curious about my position
should look at my unheard essay from
november of 2021
which i posted a link to on uh twitter
yesterday but it's called something like
the liberal case for gun ownership i'll
put it in the show so yeah it'll be in
the show notes
um
in any case i make the argument in that
piece
that the gun control advocates are and
this is going to make uh others bristle
but hear me out gun control advocates
are actually correct about the role that
ubiquitous gun ownership in the u.s has
on these shootings
i'm not arguing that this is the only
component but that is a necessary
component
for these shootings to be
as common as they have become
the question is what does the world look
like if we were to
regard the second amendment as an error
and we were to do something like
australia did with its buy-back after
they had a massacre
and that's the part that i think
changes the equation dramatically
right so the argument i made in that
article is that actually
despite the fact that the public is not
in a position to
um
to fend off tyranny in a fair fight it
is in a position to drive tyrants uh
into retreat that an inferior force can
often do that and has often done that
it's not been done to the us military
numerous times in recent history
and that the point is
a the signs of tyranny have greatly
increased over the last several years on
all kinds of fronts from the insane rush
towards
censoring one's opponents to demonizing
people according to their race according
to their vaccination status
the the official propaganda the
public-private partnerships which is
actually a euphemism for fascism right
all of these things you want to spell
that out yes the synchronon the the
signature feature of fascism is this
fusion of the state and corporate power
right
that's what public private partnership
is it's a it's a soft peddling of
fascism and public private partnerships
for those who who may not recognize that
phrase uh has been has been trotted out
in lots of quarters recently but uh
it it has been promoted as this great
win
by the now no longer
lead at the nih francis collins
one of whose chief agencies is of course
the one that fauci leads and you know he
and they both basically brought in and
made dominant in the funding structure
of science in the united states
so-called private public partnerships
which is code for the pharmaceutical the
pharmaceutical companies have their
their financial interests in the
research being done the questions that
are asked and what is then promoted and
publicized in the results right so
we have all that we have a ministry of
truth by a slightly different name which
okay yes has been put on temporary pause
because we managed to mock it out of
existence but you know so easy to mock
don't kid yourself that that thing is
going away no it's not you know as far
as i know the department of homeland
security hasn't rescinded its absurd
claim that saying true things that cause
people to distrust their government is
uh mal-information terrorism so we've
got the government threatening people
for saying uh facts that are
inconvenient right the signs of tyranny
are all around now you can say
you know your imagination's running away
with you but how much of a risk do you
want to take because at the end of the
day
these massacres are completely
unacceptable and tragic but you know
what else is completely unacceptable and
tragic
programs and gas chambers and every
other you know mass starvation struggle
sessions all of this stuff so all right
those signs are all out there and the
second amendment plays a role in
protecting us from that what's more
the argument that was always weaker
on the question of gun control which was
the right to personal self-defense
which
i don't think is in the second amendment
the second amendment is phrased in a way
that if i squint at it just right it's
possible that the founders were being
extremely clever and that they did
include it but i don't think so so the
reason the reason i say that is this the
second amendment reads
a well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed
now you could interpret free state as
the state of freedom it could be an
individual right but i don't think
that's what they meant it's a little
hard to say i believe they've
capitalized the word state which implies
that it's not personal but they also
capitalized militia and arms so maybe
they were just in a capital happy mood
was it dr alligator who was
maybe he's the doctor and he was
at the founding and he capitalized some
letters just to
leave a
note for us in the future but
the point being
i don't know what's happening uh
i'm just
we know one and only one person who's
become somewhat famous for his abuse of
of the caps lock key well that that's
totally different all caps and uh
capitalizing lots of words throughout
sentences is is rather a different form
we don't know how many hundreds of years
he's been capitalizing and he's finally
arrived at all all right we're going to
bail out of this particular
fraction of the discussion but basic
point being look the self-defense side
of this question was always the dicer
side of the argument right
the founders do not appear to have
granted us the right to bear arms in
order to defend our homes that may be
more necessary now and especially in
light i mean let's take our situation
for a second
we live
in a city
where
a certain number of people
believe us
guilty of racism
of transphobia
of um
you know
killing people by speaking about
possible vaccine hazards now these
people are crazy none of these things
will stand up to scrutiny but scrutiny
isn't what it's about the question is
how safe are we here
in that same city the police have been
demonized they don't tend to show up
when people face uh
threats their ranks are thinning their
ranks are thinning and so the point is
look
you can say well you know nobody told
you to live in portland and that's true
but then you own the downside of that
argument because for this to be america
we have to have the right to live in any
city in it or anywhere in it that we
wish to and our beliefs cannot be the
reason that we are in physical danger
right if you believe that our physical
danger because we live in a place where
there are a concentration of crazy
people who misunderstand simple logic
that that's our fault right then you
have uninvented america that's your
fault right so
in any case my point would be i think
the gun control debate i don't expect it
to end but i think it's logically over
because logically speaking you cannot
demonize the police and then not give
people the right to defend themselves
and the ability to do so and you cannot
ratchet up all of the indicators that
you are intent on a tyrannical
bullying of your enemies
and
then say well but the second amendment
is irrelevant because you know what's it
for well it's for fending off tyrants
okay you surprised me a bit um not
because the logic and what you just laid
out doesn't make sense it does
um
but because you imagine that that logic
uh
even if it were clear to all involved
uh that anyone in a position to actually
consider this
uh would pay attention like that's
that's not the political machine that we
live in no i said i don't expect the
argument to end but it is logically over
that the point is those who are
advocating in the face of this tragedy
which has come and will come again right
that we must do away with these weapons
are not paying attention to the net
argument on which they own the downside
of all of the things that they have been
doing and arguing i suspect that there
are those uh who have been considering
these issues deeply for longer than than
you have and
to some degree than i have
for less time
yet uh
we'll argue that that has been the case
many times over that there have been
there have been other events other
changes in policy and politics and
culture
that have rendered actually these
arguments
long since logically over and yet here
we are still well i guess what i would
argue then is that an honest broker
can't help but see this one right and i
think most of the people were arguing
they're not honest brokers but um and
honestly i mean let's just try to put
ourselves
one of the things one of the places we
find ourselves in the last five years is
um
happily
among
people with similar values who are on
the right
whereas we just didn't have much
opportunity to to find ourselves among
very many conservatives before
and
and
many of the things that the you know
snarkier among
the conservatives will say is this has
always been what the liberals do this is
always what they sound like uh there's a
naivete you know that's the nice that's
them being nice that's them not being
very snarky but there's a naivete to
liberal policies uh that hasn't worked
for all of these reasons for a very long
time and wake up already so you know why
why do you think that this is the moment
that ought to be waking people up and
what what previous i i guess i don't i
don't know the history well enough to
know sort of what previous moments may
be
there ought to have been conversions
happening to understand okay this is not
this is not as simple as either side
would say it is well look
i have no doubt
that those on this side that i'm
claiming has won the logical argument
here will say oh yeah we were always
right and in some sense that's true
because the central issue is one of
tyranny and it may be that tyranny is
on the horizon and evident now in a way
that it has not been
uh maybe ever in the us before
or maybe it has but
uh fairly deeply into history
but
the
um
the fact of these things being now so
ubiquitous and so aggressively on the
march means that
in effect that can't help but be the
central issue and if this isn't clear to
people i want to i want to make it
clear there is nothing as i say in my
article there is nothing that makes
these massacres the slightest bit
tolerable right there is no net argument
that makes them okay
what we have is
concrete deaths tragic deaths in large
numbers but numbers that are small
compared to what happens when tragedy
unfolds historically right so we are
talking about actual children whose
names we know
against many more children whose names
we don't know because it's an
abstraction until it happens right and
so
it's a tough argument to make because
the concrete always
outweighs the abstract in such in such a
case right the tragedy the actual
tragedy that we have is very hard to
compare to a tragedy that we might have
but the point is the order of magnitude
of the tragedy that we risk
is so great now i'm not arguing that
there is not a ton
we could do
to reduce i don't think we can eliminate
the massacre problem but i think we can
greatly reduce it if we decide to for
one thing we have to be honest about the
fact that guns may be necessary
ubiquitous guns may be necessary for
this but they are not the only thing
right there is a thread which
of course is now a sacred cow and we
can't really talk about it
but chris martinson did a very good
analysis i think yesterday
uh where he talked about pharmaceuticals
and the role that they appear to play
there's strong statistical evidence that
these are an important player in a
majority of such cases now
so this i mean i think this does bring
us full circle
um
also and into one of the other topics
that we wanted to touch on today full
circle to you know how how is it that we
find our meaning and why are so many
people
finding themselves with enough to stay
alive but without enough to actually
find meaning in their life
and
the
you know the these so-called
homelessness crisis
is at one level a crisis of of meaning
and it's a crisis of opportunity in some
cases to some degree but
addiction
both to street drugs and to legal drugs
that have been prescribed and then
sometimes also sold as street drugs and
sometimes just prescribed
and also mental illness which often is
the result of
early developmental issues which may
have to do with early prescription drugs
uh combine
into and this is this is something that
schellenberger talks about a lot in san
francisco san francisco is the name of
his his excellent book i'm not quite
done with it yet but um you know i don't
i don't agree with all of it but he
really he makes his point um carefully
and very well
um many of his points
and
it is
the point in part is
the idea that you just
have to let people do what they're doing
on the street is actually not a kindness
it's not that's not humane that's not
progressive it's not compassionate there
is nothing nice about that and no we're
not just talking for about the rich
homeowners whose streets have tents on
them it's for the people themselves the
people themselves who are trapped in
these lives some of whom will say i've
made a choice i'm here by choice
most of whom will not say that but then
addicts don't own that and those who are
mentally ill don't own that right so
there are many in the
the
homelessness
industry which is a terrible word but um
who will say absolutely not no way the
only shelter first that's the only thing
you need to do to to save people well
no
because
actually
the reason that we think that the reason
that we can be led to believe that is
because of what we have decided to call
the whole group of people who we find
defecating on sidewalks
and
walking around wearing only a blanket in
the pearl district in portland which i
saw yesterday
and yelling at random passers-by
and having those people walk around in
this walk out into the street just to
get away from like what is that what is
the situation why can't why do we have a
problem here oh it's just a kindness to
let them do that no it's not so no it's
not you've got the issue of
kindness which has been uh
weaponized
um and you have the issue of
misdiagnosis the idea that the cause of
homelessness is about homes right right
um and actually maybe we should play the
video which involves michael
schellenberger interviewing people on
the street so before so we've just we've
invoked his name a few times michael
schellenberger
is um a i don't even actually not sure
what he calls himself now certainly a
former liberal maybe still someone who
thinks of himself as a liberal
but is not understood that way by many
on the left who is running for governor
of california
is hoping to get onto the ballot for the
two-way runoff um and the primary that
will happen on june 7th in california
where if if he gets there he would then
be running against gavin newsom who's
the incumbent yes he is an independent
yes um and i believe
but there's not much republican presence
in california so it's he has a he has a
good chance but he needs to get you know
come in he needs to let's come back to
the election yeah on the other side but
let's take a look at his uh his
piece here which i think is a campaign
uh thing which involves his interviews
broad daylight i saw someone get raped i
was raped bullied picked on strip naked
somebody gets stabbed i mean like
someone robbed me with a machete today
of all my stuff
in the head with crowbars and bats
i saw you get shot in the back of the
head somebody's getting shot
do they live no you will end up getting
hurt out here the other homeless people
are like your worst enemy these people
do not play out here besides i have
weapons
i have my protections okay what kind of
weapons
bad attachments nice maze tasers and
what's your drug of choice brother uh
heroin um crystal bad methane heroin
crystal man
yeah
[Music]
we saw a woman who was pregnant just now
what is she smoking vinnie
she's smoking fentanyl and she's eight
months pregnant yeah so are you seeing
more people showing up in psychotic
states naked now than say two three
years ago yes i think so i don't know
what they're putting in this stuff i
don't know if it was aliens
i'm not trying to sound crazy
must be
um causing all these like psychological
breakdowns and i think that they had put
like a transmitter or something because
i was able to hear and communicate and
it looked like i was talking to myself
my job was to intake homeless
individuals on the street because i
don't have to be on the streets
you just choose to be a lot of people
around here because they want to be out
here everyone
i mean everyone's usually has a serious
drug problem they kind of just kind of
quit society this right now is it's
literally by choice did you get the
sense of have cared about that they're
wrong
and i'm not trying to be like crazy with
it but definitely not i mean we're going
to be realistic they pay you to be
homeless here they make it so easy
and normalize it drug dealers are just
being let go over and over and over it's
like the cops were
it's like they're your neighbor you know
they enable them because they allow the
open-air drug market open street dealing
like that with the cops just across the
street like
watching them i think they've given up
on the people that are out there on the
street i've never seen anything like it
i've been in the game for [ __ ] 30
years dude
never seen anything like it
all right so
i want to make a couple points about
what you've just seen that's obviously a
campaign ad it's designed to persuade
you but nonetheless you can see his
interviews and i do think we have to say
something about the
courage and dedication
that is apparent in a candidate for
governor
actually spending as much time with the
homeless as he clearly has to do these
interviews i've watched many of them
and he clearly he's humane about it he
you know he treats them
very decently
and he they tell him things because he's
obviously a genuine guy who's interested
to know
but the obvious upshot
is that this homelessness crisis is not
about homes it's about something else
primarily it's about drugs and if you
think back to the beginning of our
conversation today
the problem is the truth and mental
illness which he separates somewhat in
the book yeah it is about both and
actually you could
you could
you could make drugs a subset of mental
illness because effectively what these
things do is they hijack systems and
they cause you to you know prioritize
your next high over the kind of
investment that might result in you
having a roof over your head
but
in any case it's powerful stuff and it's
also not his own his only issue
i will say that i have a misgiving about
michael schellenberger which i want to
share with you
when i first became aware of michael
schellenberger it was because his
signature issue was about nuclear power
and i believe he has it dead wrong right
and
here's
here's what i'm going to say
i hope that ultimately
he prevails in this election
he displaces gavin newsom from the
governor's office and then we get to
have that conversation about the reality
of nuclear power i know he's very
compelled i've heard his argument and i
believe i know what's wrong with it
um maybe his position is uh
vision extant fission power is the wave
of the way of the future right keep keep
the plants open why would we close these
things energy independence uh
comparatively clean power etcetera and
it's not that i don't understand his
point i just think there's a point above
it that inverts the conclusion
but nonetheless
here's what i would say you and i are
not californians anymore but we
certainly both grew up there
we both have family in california in
fact most of our family remains uh our
immediate family remains in california
and uh we love the place
and
my sense is
the emergency that is happening in all
of the west coast states especially
california but not exclusively is so
great
that we have to put aside even major
differences right i think nuclear power
is a
devastating and dangerous issue
for which we have largely been spared
the downside so far
but that will not go on forever
nonetheless i think the emergency that
is faced by california is so much
greater than that that i even in light
of the fact that a
um a shellenberger presidency would
likely have a presidency a governorship
would likely
increase the amount of nuclear power
would keep plants open that i think
should be shut down i think we have to
risk it so um
i don't know that endorse is the right
word since we're not californians but i
i feel like embracing this candidacy and
suggesting to those who do have a vote
in california that you very seriously
consider
voting for michael schellenberger he
appears to be genuine he appears to be a
broad thinker and the test
i mean we know what gavin newsom is
right he's a
machine politician
uh who is um
deeply corrupt as part of a
long-standing california and national
political machine and he's been quite
willing to go along with both woke and
medically woke uh politics and policies
absolutely he's got to go yeah and i
don't see a a better
prospect on the horizon so we will you
know hopefully he will be displaced by
michael shellenberger and when he is
hopefully we will discover that michael
schellenberger is
interested in bringing the right people
on to actually refine his position on
all these issues which i would imagine
would reverse his position on nuclear
but who knows
and i would say you know i i
teased on twitter about
how we're going to get out of our
predicament and i would point out that
it is the moment right it has been the
moment for some time but most people
couldn't see it i think people now are
beginning to get a sense for just how
broken our system is and just how
entrenched
dangerous forms of power have become and
the fact is
we have to take evasive action and it's
going to look unusual it's going to look
like michael schellenberger it's going
to look like andrew yang it's going to
look like unity 2020 right
and you know i think we are all fellow
travelers trying to figure out well i
mean
let's go back a little farther
there were there were good honorable
people who thought that it looked like
occupy who thought that it looked like
the tea party who thought that it looked
like donald trump yep right all three of
those two of which were
organizations rather than individuals
right and you know loose aggregates of
organizations in the in the case of the
first two
who show up on supposedly completely
opposite sides
of some very very important political
offense
but all three of those cases
occupy tea party trump were in fact
outside of the system at at least some
important level looking in and saying
this won't work this will not work this
must be broken down and that is in part
uh what i think you know andrew
that that that could be at least
translated into something that andrew
yang is on about uh that michael
schoelenberger schellenberger is on
about
uh and that that many of these well dark
horse candidates are are on about
yes um
[Music]
yes and some of us have been on this a
very long time and you're right there
have been you know game b is also uh
an indicator that a bunch of people were
registering the fact that we had a
critical problem before most people
could see it
so yes all of these things are attempts
to do
something that will displace power in
some way
that we can write right the ship let me
say that i mean bernie sanders appeared
to be that as well and so you know to go
back what seems like into ancient
history at this point but remember when
all of the so-called bernie bros
um when when bernie left the race and um
gave his vote to hillary a bunch of
people famously you know anonymous
people but we heard endlessly about all
of these people who had been supporters
of bernie sanders who are now supporting
donald trump and no one in the
mainstream media could possibly
comprehend this it made no sense because
the politics appeared to be entirely
different
but they shared something fundamental
they shared an understanding of a deep
rot in the system that needed to go yes
um there is a problem
uh my way of viewing it has been capture
and what i would call recapture we have
to take back the system
and people have
frankly engaged in all kinds of
desperate hail mary
plays but to the extent that we have um
a candidate running in california who
appears to be
a
a thinking person and somebody
interested in solutions that are not
existing on the map solutions that are
born of an understanding that is deeper
than the one that we are handed
i think i think it makes a great deal of
sense
to go with it
i would add that part of the problem
that blocks this
the reason that censorship matters so
much and the reason that elon
musk's play to free twitter right it is
a recapture play right return twitter to
the public right that is effectively
what he claims to want to do and i think
he wants to do
um the reason that that matters
is that the censorship is the mechanism
by which we are kept from understanding
that it is that moment at which we must
retake our system
right if we had had a natural discussion
through all of covet 19 we would have a
very clear understanding of how
desperately broken our system is and the
fact that it belongs to other people who
do not hold
our well-being in high regard that would
be obvious we don't have agreement on
that
because we all live in various halls of
mirrors in which some phony story is
kept alive by the fact that those who
challenge it are you know stigmatized
demonized driven from the platforms and
all of this and the fact is
the net analysis right
is
as we said earlier in the in the podcast
it is the conversation the open
conversation through which we figure out
what is true
how do you maximize the preservation of
human life and human health through
figuring out what's true about disease
and remedy right you get there through
an open conversation if you can get
people by threatening them and by making
examples of those who step out of line
you can make themselves censor then the
point is yes you may get your policy
instead of the right policy
but what's the result the result is um
a lot of people being less healthy than
they would be and so the point is look
censorship kills right we have to escape
that dynamic and we have to figure out
again how we are going to have open
conversations not so that we can speak
the truth but so that we can figure out
together what the truth is that's the
point of the exercise right
and so anyway i will get off my soapbox
but
um
this is an interesting moment the fact
that we have multiple uh
highly capable players showing up ready
to challenge power is encouraging
um i hope andrew yang will think
carefully about what's coming his way if
he attempts a third party run um in the
midst of an election that would will
surely be portrayed as a spoiler life or
death moment for the republic yes he
will be portrayed as a spoiler and there
are ways out of that right
it's time to dust off
the unity proposal and figure out how to
structure things to defeat the lesser
evil paradox
but nonetheless let's go we got to
recapture the system and we got to do it
now there's not there's not a lot of
time
all right
um
maybe just a reminder of uh frankel's
taxonomy categories of uh ways to find
meaning
creating a work or doing a deed the
second is by experiencing something or
encountering someone in other words
meaning can be found not only in work
but also in love
and third
even the helpless victim of a hopeless
situation facing a fate he cannot change
may rise above himself may grow beyond
himself and by so doing change himself
he may turn a personal tragedy into a
triumph
i feel like all of us
can find meaning in all three of those
ways and we should be actively seeking
to do so
and
too often
now it is easy to become hopeless
and to act helpless
and to play the victim and to look at
all of the powers arranged against a
person
and uh an organization and a set of
meetings and say there's nothing i can
do
but you yourself as an individual can
still find meaning
and in so doing
probably helped change the world
yeah i agree i would say i see a
hierarchy in there what you want to do
is prioritize the making of meaning in
those first two ways so you're not
forced to do it in that third way
but
one way or the other it's the
the highest priority so
well we're all living through something
that is
deeply unfortunate right now and and
some of us have more uh more of an
awareness of it than others uh and some
of us are you know living the actual
effects you know there
again i mentioned
on our last show
uh you know we still don't have complete
freedom of movement among all of the
sort of cultural and culinary entities
in the city in which we live because we
have chosen not to get the experimental
vaccines against covet that are neither
safe nor effective
but at least we don't live in canada
where not having done so means that you
are really quite prescribed in terms of
where you are allowed to go and how you
are allowed to move through the universe
that is extraordinary
many people who do not find themselves
having made that choice are unaware and
would rather not be reminded of this
and
it is
an uncomfortable and unsavory position
to be constantly reminding others of it
but the fact is it persists and it will
only grow worse
as it is allowed to continue uh to to
make inroads as
as as as you have said brett uh the
totalitarianism is making inroads in
both the u.s and canada and elsewhere as
well
maybe just one last quick recommendation
we watched ricky gervais's new special
last night super nature and uh it's
terrific and you know i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna give anything away except to
say i've never before heard a stand-up
routine that included a joke about
monotremes
to say those wacky mammals at the base
of the mammalian tree the echidnas and
the duckbill platypus and that alone at
least for an evolutionary biologist was
worth the price of admission so highly
recommend that yeah i would say it's the
kind of routine that has something to
offend everyone
i don't
does that say something i'm not sure i
was offended you weren't oh surely no
well i mean he does a beauty i mean i
think that's really the whole
point of the thing i'm not gonna you
know go analytical on a funny routine
and yeah and uh risk wrecking it but i
do think he sort of had a meta point um
and the way he went about this uh i
thought was pretty effective at making
it yeah
awesome okay
uh well
we will be back here same time
next week
uh with uh with the livestream number
129 in the meantime
we're going to take a short break and
we'll be back with live q a you can ask
questions at
it's not on the stream
it's not on the screen right now it is
at
darkhorsesubmissions.com you can ask
questions there
and we will have uh
beginning this upcoming tuesday and for
many weeks to come there will be a bret
hosted guest episode of dark horse uh
weekly um from now into you know maybe
infinity strongly
strongly but rather than weekly
weekly
spelled differently
not helpful
you see what i have to live with guys oh
my god
i don't i can't actually model whether
they have sympathy they probably do have
sympathy over it yeah i have no idea um
so questions um that you have for us
that you would like us to answer we
won't get to all of them we will get to
as many as we can
in the hour that we do starting in about
10 15 minutes with the link that you'll
find
right here where you're watching us now
or on youtube and hopefully honestly if
we get that back up and running
soon in the meantime be good to the ones
you love eat good food and get outside
rock on
[Music]
you